[Music]
what's up guys this is Angelo I'm the
buzz feeder I'm about to head out for
the streets of New York City to see if
New Yorkers can really tell fact from
fiction now everybody knows who New
Yorkers are known for being able to
smell [ __ ] a mile away so I'm gonna
put them to the test
[Music]
I am standing instead in our I live in
Washington Heights Upper West Side okay
anything that you got a pretty good
[ __ ] detector pretty good
what about like pop culture you you kind
of up on movies and stuff I know more 90
stuff than I do stuff today all right so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give you
three facts two of them are true one of
them is made up he's got to pick what
you think it's fake one
here's your crew second Snoop Dogg is a
voice option on TomTom GPS systems Star
Trek had the first interracial kiss to
be broadcast on television and the third
is that Bambi is America's favorite
movie animal I think the first time you
think this noob dog is not a voice
option
I just don't think that Snoop Dogg would
would do something like that I think
that's that's crap you [ __ ] the Bambi I
think I don't think Bambi's America's
number one you don't know you're
incorrect so Bambi according to a study
is America's favorite movie and OnStar
[Music]
perfect Sylvester Stallone wrote the
original rocky script in three and a
half days second fact Hugh Hefner owns a
Crips next to Marilyn Monroe's and then
Sinbad played a genie in the 90s movies
Shazam I think it's number one I think
it's the first one how about the first
one writing the script in three days
even got false yeah if you're in fact
yeah he wrote rocky and green out Dave
man so one has facing life though what
do I know
I mean I just know YouTube
[Music]
we got one more set of facts for you
here okay your first back in Forrest
Gump Kurt Russell reportedly provided
the voice of Elvis Presley number an
Elvis is there dancing a PETA knew how
to dance
our second fact is that Carrie Fisher
aka Princess Leia 3 wrote damn Park
Strikes Back script and the third one
Johnny Depp and Marilyn Manson have
matching tattoos
I think it's a second do you think the
Carrie Fisher didn't really write Empire
Strikes Back
yeah Princess Leia did not rewrite the
entire empire sprites Thanks so let's go
the last one on Johnny Depp
third you can get Johnny Depp the real
map and don't have matching tattoos oh
you're incorrect Johnny Depp in
blackmail Manson do have some essence
tattoos they talked about it in an
article
[Music]
[Music]
I feel pretty bad a lot of credit goes
to Sylvester Stallone sorry I didn't
trust in you I guess I have to you know
really keep himself on this yeah you
gotta brush up on your 80s movies yeah
I've got a trophy for you participation
no trophy farmer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]